what you got is what you got and
obviously they're secondary buyout
market stuff and that's
i'll leave that up to chris mannix who
uh joins me right now
on twitter at s i chris maddox he's a
senior writer
for sports illustrate also the host of
the crossover podcast
and chris uh so far any surprises so far
as we head to the deadline for the trade
for the trade deadline
um i think chicago's aggressive move
to get nicola vucevic was something of a
surprise
uh vucevic was available with orlando as
we can see the magic are kind of now
going all
in on a teardown but the asking price
was believed to be pretty high it was
pretty high i mean the bulls gave up
our real assets to get vucevic away but
they believe
that having a 30 year old all-star and
vucevic
a mid-20s all-star in zach levine that
that was a pretty good foundation to
build on
uh other than that you knew evan
fournier was going to move
you knew aaron gordon was going to move
and now
as we kind of sit here it's it's just
sort of waiting on kyle lowry
at this point and you know the raptors
are committed to dealing him in the next
40 minutes
uh you saw them make the move that sent
norman powell to portland that's a
pretty strong indication
of of their direction um whether it is i
believe just the the heat and lakers are
the two teams that are
are currently bidding uh one of those
two teams i believe will get kyle lowry
what do you think is the compensation
for a kyle lowry because we know the
lakers and
um you know a lot of other teams don't
necessarily have first round pick so
what could the compensation be
for a kyle lowry well neither the lakers
or he
have first-round picks they can deal
miami
could get creative a little bit and go
to oklahoma city to try to have some of
the protections
that are on picks they've traded them in
the past lifted
uh but you know draft compensation is
not going to be
the centerpiece of this deal it's going
to be young players and both the heat
and lakers
have young pieces to offer the lakers
will include
dennis schroeder in a a deal
for kyle lowry schroeder is having
another excellent season
after being i think it was runner-up for
six man of the year last year
um so that's a piece but the the raptors
are gonna hold out i mean
you know taylon horton tucker is the
jewel
of this lakers young group and that's
someone i believe the raptors want to
get their hands on
and in miami while the heat are willing
to deal duncan robinson
they are not at this point willing to
deal tyler hero
because in part hiro is still on that
rookie contract
it's a manageable salary and he's really
good he hasn't had the type of season
this year
that we saw him have in the bubble but
you're still talking about a 19 20 year
old guard
who can shoot the basketball and that's
not someone that the heat are
looking to part with so it's a game of
cat mouse that could could break any
second
he's a senior writer for sports
illustrated he's chris mannix also
the host of the crossover podcast um
we're watching kind of the denver
nuggets make a couple moves today right
they add
uh javel mcgee they had aaron gordon and
now you look at this team
are they really big time contenders now
in the western conference have they
caught
sort of the utah jazz the lakers the
clippers
well i think they've improved
significantly um
you know mcgee was a nice small deal
they lost mason plumley in free agency
last year
and didn't really replace him so now you
get a guy who
they're familiar with in denver played
there a few years or some years back now
uh and he's got championship experience
so
you know that's a good guy to have
coming off your bench and the gordon
deal makes a lot of sense
uh you know he's a versatile guy can
play 3-4 probably best fit
as a four-man right now who can you know
play alongside michael
michael porter or you know replace him
in different lineups
look the nuggets they saw what they were
they were a team that was
good but not good enough to win a
championship this year
which is why they pushed their chips to
the middle of the table put a first
round pick in that package that included
gary harris
and got that deal done uh and now i
don't know
where they stand you have to see how
these guys kind of fit in first
but the nuggets you know one of the part
of their mindset was that this
at least the western conference is
pretty wide open right now i mean the
lakers
they could wind up in the play-in
tournament you know depending on how far
they fall
uh in the absence of lebron and anthony
davis the jazz are good but they're
unproven
um you know the clippers they've got
problems of their own you know
there's a there's an opening here for
any team that makes the playoffs to come
out
of the western conference and i think
the nuggets saw that and that's why they
got aggressive at the final hours
you mentioned playoffs still chris and
for me a guy whose name is i think
now starting to hear more and more in
the rumors um
is playoff rondo roshan rondo and i know
there's some teams that are probably in
play for him
um what do you think or where do you see
rajon rondo going
maybe at this tread deadline uh or even
in the buyout market
well there have been discussions between
the hawks and the clippers
about a rondo deal the clippers have
been proactive
in looking for a guard to to
supplement their back court they've got
real problems
at the play making positions they rank
around the bottom third of the league
and assists
you know patrick beverly lou williams
these are not
play makers uh they're they're good in
their own rights williams is a scorer
and beverly's defender
but they're not playmakers they need
something in that mix
they've talked about ricky rubio he's
still available
george hill was someone on their radar
but he was traded today to philadelphia
and now
you've got rondo uh currently in the mix
uh rhonda would be a good addition for
the clippers we know about his playoff
experience how he steps up his game
every postseason and he's exactly what
the doctor ordered a guy that
you know can just find paul george find
kawhi leonard get them easy shots
play well in transition uh yeah that
would be i think a strong
and badly needed pickup for the clippers
you know as this
trade deadline is approaching the one
thing i'm just kind of been looking at
over the last couple days is that
obviously we think it's going to be an
nba finals between the
los angeles lakers and the brooklyn nets
is there any concern with what's going
on in los angeles right now with lebron
james obviously his ankle injury
they think he'll return which he'll be
fine but with anthony davis and the
caution that they've had
you know with his injury does that make
the lakers feel like they may
need to make a move or just kind of hope
that the rest that both these guys will
get
they'll be ready to go come play off
time well if you have a chance to add
a kyle lowry and not give up a horton
tucker in that deal
you've got to go at least try i mean
dennis schroeder's been excellent for
this team they were oh and four
about a month ago when schroeder was out
in the health and safety protocols
his value there's a numeric number
attached to that value so
uh i think they'd be fine standing pat
but going to get
a kyle lowry would obviously upgrade
that team you know
i i think for the lakers it's all about
when they get a d and lebron back
and how healthy they are going into the
playoffs if both those guys have
a month to shake the rust off and get
past their injury problems lakers gonna
be fine it doesn't really matter where
they
they finish the season home court
advantage is largely meaningless this
year even if
you know some fans are allowed to
trickle back into most buildings
um and the lakers in lebron's career
his teams have have one on the road the
lakers has no reason to believe
they can't do it either so to me it's
less about what the lakers do now
what they do in the buyout market as
just how healthy
and how sharp are lebron and ad come
playoff time
chris mannix senior writer for sports
illustrated here on the rich eisen show
kirk morrison
and for rich and you know there was a
news this week that you know kyrie
irving is going to spend a little time
away
uh personal matter won't you know go on
a road trip and then you still have the
kevin durant situation they do
add blake griffin we know from from the
buy out market but
how are we viewing brooklyn right now is
it still this process of
they are still getting themselves
together and don't worry everything will
be fine by the playoffs
or is it still are they the favorite in
the east
and not necessarily the 76ers who right
now currently have the best spot
in the india in the eastern conference
no i i think you make brooklyn the
favorite
in the east i mean the sixers have been
out there
scouring the trade market for more back
court debt they got george hill he's
fine but
i'm not sure he's you know some kind of
difference-making upgrade whereas the
the nets have just kind of sat back and
said we need to get our guys healthy
and then we need to scour the buyout
market where they're going to be big
players i mean one name to watch
with the nets over the next week or so i
think is going to be jj redick i mean jj
reddick has not played particularly well
with the pelicans the pelicans are going
nowhere this season
i could see the pelicans coming to an
agreement with reddick for a buyout
and reddick spends his offseasons in
brooklyn he has a house
in brooklyn and he would be i think an
ideal fit
with that nets team which could use
another shooter playing opposite durant
and kyrie and james harden so uh you
know the nets
are not doing anything at the trade
deadline but
they may not be done and even if they
aren't they are done uh
having three snipers like harden durant
and irving
you're just gonna be really tough for
anybody to beat well i know whoever gets
uh andre drummond he'll be well rested
right he's has been doing
a little bit of anything but tell me
about andre drummond know what
what's what's it look like over the next
couple days for him
well drummond is eventually going to get
waved
or just or bought out i mean there's a
question i've been told about how much
money drummond is willing to give back
to cleveland
i'm told not nothing at all and that it
make me delay that a little bit
as they try to work that out but he'll
eventually be a free agent
uh you know the the marquee teams are
gonna go after him the lakers
you know i i think they might be able to
promise him a starting role
uh with that team which i think would be
appealing to andre drummond the clippers
will make a run and the nets will make a
run at him
the knicks are interesting because the
knicks
from what i'm hearing the knicks may be
willing to do more than just give andre
drummond
uh rest of the season type of contract
they may be willing to offer him
something
with their cap flexibility that extends
into next season if the number's right
that could become appealing to drama
it's a weird offseason this year
where not a ton of teams have cap space
and and even more
the teams that do aren't looking to to
spend on andre drummond like oklahoma
city is not going to to chase andre
drummond this offseason so
i i keep one eye on the knicks as far as
drummond goes if they're willing to go
into a second year
at a reasonable number uh that could be
enough to entice drummond away from one
of the projected title contenders
is there any other names on that buyout
market that we should be
aware of because in the buyout market
you're just grabbing
grabbing guys they're more depth than
anything they're not going to
change the way your roster or how you
play the game but any more depth guys
that we should keep an eye out for
well marcus aldridge is the big name
that'll be out there at some point
um he'll get a buy out from san antonio
i've been told miami
is in a strong position there uh
you know phoenix would be a team to
watch with aldridge as well he almost
signed there
back in 2015 and now that's a team
obviously on the rise that could use him
but
i i think with the way miami is made up
um
you know aldridge could step in there
and i think have a big role
with that team whether it's backing up
bam adebayo playing alongside him
um i i think miami's in a good position
for lamarcus aldridge
senior writer for sports illustrated
chris mannix joining the rich eisen show
kirk morrison here filling in for rich
um kind of get your opinion on this one
chris because
i think last year the nba wanted to see
how it would work and
that play-in sort of tournament format
it gave you something maybe it might
have been
um the the best basketball but it gave
you something
and i thought it entertained me and to
see them going back to it again this
year
and to seeing what it has done for a
team like the chicago bulls so
any other year they're probably worried
about next season but because they have
an opportunity
to have a chance to make true playoffs
and not just to play in
do you think the nba is now getting it
right they like this when they want to
keep it going and moving forward
uh i i think there'll be some
modifications to it if it
exists beyond this year uh the plane
tournament has been
you know really good it's been fun it's
also kind of slowed the trade deadline
down a little bit because there are
teams out there
like a sacramento and others that you
know are within
you know shouting distance of of that
plane tournament and that
uh makes them less likely to kind of
tear things down and
and make a deal uh i don't think you'll
have 10 teams have an opportunity i
think that'll be whittled down
uh i think you probably could see nine
teams uh be in the mix but only
if that ninth team is within like one
game
or two games of that eighth and final
playoff spot it's not going to be a
situation
where you know the top eight are teams
of above 500 records and
the ninth seat team is below 500 but
they have a chance to
get in the playoff to the play and
there'll be some tweaks to it but i do
think some version of it
is probably here to stay because it does
make
the end of the season a lot more
compelling the nba's had a problem with
that historically
where in the last month of the season
you've got teams tanking you've got
uh just bad basketball overall this will
at least
increase on some in some level the the
quality of the game in the final months
last question before i let you go chris
um i know i was
with some friends this weekend and we're
just talking about basketball we're
talking about just the
um you know the nba's rookie of the year
i know lamela ball is
going to probably be out for the season
to be reevaluated after having the wrist
surgery but
right now who is your rookie of the year
in the nba
well the melo as we sit is is a clear
rookie of the year the question is going
to be
will he be that in a month and a half um
patrick ewing has
the the the lowest number of games
played
to win rookie of the year that was 50
back in 1986 uh lamela will of course
finish below that if he's done for the
season
but the competition is not great i mean
anthony edwards has had a solid year
with minnesota but you can certainly
argue that there's a lot of empty
calories there for a bad minnesota team
uh james wiseman's had his moments
tyrese halliburton
has had his moments i think voters and
i'm one of them are going to have to
decide
if you know kind of the way lamelo
played for 41 games
uh carries more value than the way other
players played for
60 or 70 games or whatever they finish
with at the end of the season
i i put a lot of value in players that
impact winning and there's no question
lamelo impacted winning
in his 41 games with the charlotte
hornets and if you look around
no none of the other guys did i mean the
teams the players were talking about the
teams that they're on
you know not very good um in general so
uh i lean towards lamela regardless of
if he's out for the season but
you know it's a very fluid situation you
could see anthony evers go on the kind
of care
that you know kind of forces you to vote
for him same thing with halliburton if
the kings can get back in the playoff
mix
uh there's a lot of variables still in
play there yeah but this is a real time
this is how we call
it live radio live television chris
because as we've been speaking the
clippers have made that deal for um
rajon rondo they give up
the they gave up lou williams so
williams for rondo
um i guess in two second round picks
just your uh your
live reaction and thoughts on the trade
and no surprise
that the clippers found a playmaker it
was priority number one for them
you know over the last few days uh
williams could be an interesting name in
the bio market
um if he's not rerouted uh in a trade
which i we're getting
damn close to the end of the deadline uh
you could see williams bought out and
look he's a former six man of the year
winner who could
score so there will be a market for lou
williams as a bio candidate that hawks
part ways with him
well i guess there's going to be a lot
to talk about on the crossover podcast
with you
and howard beck so make sure you all
listen to that man appreciate the time
chris
you guys no problem yes chris manick
senior writer for sports illustrated
at i chrismanics on twitter
and the co-host with howard beck of the
crossover podcast
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here